if you have goals that mean something to
you and you are making progress towards
them
you will not hate your life the point of
job is to learn and make money to
survive if you don't know what your
mission is the most important first step
is to figure what your mission is
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I see a lot of
entrepreneurs who are not happy with
their business they're not happy with
their life and it's it's just it's so
sad and so depressing because
entrepreneurs are the ones trying to
make the world better for other people
and if you are not happy with what
you're doing yourself there's no way
that you can bring positivity out into
the world so today we're gonna look at
the seven reasons why you are not happy
and how to fix them all so if you want
to know my strategies and the strategies
of other successful entrepreneurs and
how to build confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you in
30 seconds a 5 minute video for free
delivered to your inbox to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
[Music]
let's just jump into it number one
you're doing what your parents want you
to do and sometimes that's a good thing
but rarely it's off-track it's very rare
that the path the exact path that you
want is the exact same path that your
parents want and I can't tell you how
many young entrepreneurs I meet on a
daily basis who are writing to me who
are deeming me who are messaging me who
are meeting me and saying I want to do
this but my parents don't support me at
some point you need to decide whose life
you're gonna live your life or your
parents life and having that honest
conversation and telling them this is my
dream I understand that you love me have
empathy I understand that you love me
that you want the best for me but this
is my dream I need to try it I'm not
trying to disrespect you I'm not trying
to disrespect the family I need to try
this for me it may not work out you know
what stats show that it probably won't
work out but I need to try because
otherwise I'll live the rest of my life
in regret I need to try it and I hope
that if I fail you'll still be there for
me because I love you and I need your
support through this approaching it from
that angle it's a lot easier than how
most people have the discussion with
their parents and so it's on you being
the bigger person and you may say well
I'm the younger one I'm the child why do
I have to be the bigger person
stop complaining stop putting
expectations on them be the bigger
person own it eat it grow from it it'll
allow you to do things that your parents
didn't even think we're possible this is
the first step in your growth and at the
end of the day they still don't support
you then you have a tough decision to
make at what point are you gonna say
this is my life you know you're gonna be
30 and still listen to your parents or
15 still listen to your parents at what
point do you say thank you for raising
me I love you I respect you appreciate
you and now it's time for me to stand on
my own two feet and deal with the
consequences and go off and build your
dream you will not be happy living your
parents version of your life
[Music]
number two you're hanging out with
friends who don't support you there's
another big one
most people's friends suck think about
your friends think about the friends you
had growing up a lot of these people
they're just complaining they're they're
complaining about their boss they're
complaining about their jobs they're
complaining about the presidents are
complaining about the economy they're
just complaining and blaming other
people and that is not the path to
getting out of your circumstances that
is not the path to get you where you
need to go sometimes friends are
supportive of the idea that you have the
dream that you have a lot of times
though friends there not a lot of times
or friends to say you can't do that come
on you didn't go to school for that you
think you can do that are you crazy
you're not gonna be able to do that
thing and so hanging around people who
don't support you you know family is one
thing cuz you got family for life but
friends I look at one of two things one
dropping friends who are who are
negative who don't support you just just
straight out drop them they're not
supporting you you don't want them in
your life anymore
and others who might be slightly
positive but still complain and blame
and eat and they can't help you get to
where you need to go it doesn't mean you
have to drop them but I'd be limiting my
exposure the more time you spend with
people who are negative and Debbie
downers and just the world is against
them the more that starts to infect you
and you want to be around it and so you
might still get together with your
buddies every now and then and watch a
game or play some basketball or or with
your girlfriends and you'll get a nails
nails done or whatever it is but just
limiting your exposure to negativity to
small thinking not in the judgmental way
not like I'm thinking big and you think
small and you suck you don't need to
criticize and reg them just having that
in your environment pulls you down and
so limiting your exposure to that or
cutting it from your life is the path to
leave space for other things that it
will allow you to move forward
[Music]
number three is you're chasing money not
a mission a lot of entrepreneurs when
they get started they're chasing money
you're chasing money you look at the
magazine of the top 50 hottest startups
to do in 2018 you think that's the one
you're gonna do and you end up losing
like the people who Ling are the one who
are who are mission driven money is
important it's absolutely important it's
just not number one there's something
above money and the people who are
Purpose Driven the people who feel like
they are here to do something powerful
and meaningful are the happiest people
people feel like they're on a purpose
and they have that awareness to know
what their mission is they are the
happiest people and the ones who don't
have a purpose ones who are doing
something just for money they end up
doing work that they hate he ended up
doing work that you don't like just
because you're trying to make money and
if you're in survival mode I get it
you know you got to do what you do to
survive but try to pick at least a job
if you're gonna have a job pick a job
that is helping you learn the skills you
can go on launch your mission it's the
people who take a job in something
totally different from what they
actually want to do you're not learning
anything over here the point of job is
to learn and make money to survive and
the more money you make down this path
the harder is to jump off and go do the
thing that you want to do so you get
trapped in this cycle and it's a cage
you create it for yourself so you've got
to do that thing if you're gonna have a
job make sure it's any industry that you
want to be in and have a mission if you
don't know what your mission is the most
important first step is to figure what
your mission is you will never be happy
unless you figure out what your mission
and your purpose is so many people just
drowned themselves out they drown out
the noise and sit down on the couch and
watch Netflix all day because they don't
want to do the work of figuring out what
their purpose is if you don't know what
your mission is it needs to be your
immediate priority and then start
planning for that to happen whether it's
part-time now because they have a job
taking a job in your industry learning
more and slowly slowly slowly making
your way to do your mission on a
full-time basis is the path to achieving
happiness
[Music]
number four is you're not serving people
enough I believe that people are built
to serve I think there's some people who
love serving just the five closest
people to them their friends our family
like immediate friends closest family so
maybe the five to fifty people in your
in your inner circle and your internet
work those are the people that you want
to help and others are built to serve
the world others are built to have like
a big purpose a big mission not just the
closest people to us but if you are not
happy right now chances are you are not
serving others enough and so I've been
looking at wine identifying what is the
thing that you love doing who do you
want to help I like the world I like
math I want to help a billion people
right it's not so much the one of ones
that I love as much I want to help the
world where other people like Nina my
wife loves helping individual she likes
the one I want she doesn't want to go
out and have a huge impact but she cares
deeply about the people who are
connected to her she stays in touch with
people who she knew in grade one and
still in touch with them and still
finding ways to care and help and love
them so whether you're doing on a big
massive scale or just helping people in
your closest circle don't judge just
figure out the one that's best for you
but if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving those people enough
you're not having a big enough impact on
those closest people or the bigger
mission the number five reason why you
are not happy is you're not building
self-respect a lot of people are not
happy with themselves because they don't
love themselves they don't have respect
for themselves so how do you build
self-respect self-respect
I believe comes from setting goals for
yourself setting challenges for yourself
doing something that will help you
progress and then going off and
accomplishing it or think so many people
are doing the same thing day in day out
digging they rinse repeat copy and paste
the same day over and over and over and
over again there is no progress there is
no chance of progress and so you lose
respect for yourself and you become
unhappy where if you challenge yourself
if you create a goal for yourself you
say you're gonna do something and then
you attempt to do it one thing you
actually is what's interesting whether
you actually accomplish it or not just
the process of trying builds your
self-respect so whether you say as an
example I'm going to film a YouTube
video every week for the next year
that's my
you better make sure you do it now it
doesn't matter the results of that video
it's just did you do the work or not did
you actually make the video and put it
up it's easy when it's easy if you have
all week to do it and there's no you
know pressure for you and you can bang
it out and it's a super easy thing to do
then it won't actually build your
self-respect
but if it's hard and it's challenging
and you get up when you do it then you
start building that credibility with
yourself then you say I did it it was
hard but I still did it I'm the kind of
person who does difficult things I'm the
kind of person who sees things through
now you're starting to build
self-respect up so I like to use the
example of racing against
three-year-olds if you're running a race
against a three-year-old you're gonna
win it's easy it's it's not a it's
nowhere near a contest if you win that
race you could you could win it crawling
you know if you win that race it doesn't
make you feel great because the bar was
set so incredibly low but if you ran a
race against people who are even better
than you even if you lost even if you
knew you're gonna lose going in because
you're going against people who are
faster than you just the fact that you
lined up and you said yes and you tried
your best we'll be building up your
self-respect you will feel better about
yourself for having tried that scary
thing even though you lost and you beat
them you won the race against
three-year-olds and you lose the race
against the athletes you will feel
better about yourself for racing against
the athletes and so that's the point
when you set a goal for yourself has to
be something that's at the edge of your
comfort zone and whether you get a
positive result or not it's just about
actually doing the work it's actually
about following through like you said
you would follow through to build up
your self-respect and when you respect
yourself you're gonna feel happier too
[Music]
reason number six why you're not happy
is you don't have inspiring goals so
many people who don't know what they
want in life and they have no goals to
shoot towards it's really sad it's
really the prescient kind of like the
mission a lot of people have no idea
what kind of goals they have for
themselves and so as a result you just
wake up when you keep going back to that
job that you hate you keep hanging
around these friends who bring you down
and keep going home and binging on
Netflix and or your ice cream oh my god
or a scream haven't had it a long time I
love our ice cream you keep binging on
your Oreo ice cream and that's just a
rinse and repeat every single day in and
day out where when you start to set
goals for yourself
powerful goals inspiring goals and you
start making some progress on it doesn't
even have to be that big a goal yet it
just has to be closer to the edge of
your comfort zone something that is
pushing you a little bit to step outside
what you normally do when people are
inspired when people have a goal that
means something to them they start
working towards it and as you start
making progress on it you start feeling
happier when you set a challenge for
yourself like I want this Bowl to happen
and then you do it and you make progress
towards it you start feeling better you
start feeling happier people start
looking at you differently you start
standing up straighter you start walking
on with a smile on your face you don't
have to be like goofy crazy smile all
day long but you won't hate your life if
you have goals that mean something to
you and you are making progress towards
them
you will not hate your life and so set
some meaningful and powerful goals for
yourself
[Music]
in the number-7 reason why you are not
happy and how to fix it is you don't
believe in yourself you could have the
biggest mission in the world you can
have the best goals in the world you can
have a lot of things lined up for
yourself but if you don't believe that
you can go off and do that crazy thing
if you don't believe that you can do
that little thing and you won't as long
as you have all these doubts and
insecurities and lack of self-confidence
and you won't go off and do that thing
the best way that I know how to get out
of that funk is what I've built with the
254 series it's how I've done it myself
I've built belief in myself by consuming
the videos on my content the more I hang
around Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey and
these successful people the more bleeds
into me and feeds my self belief to go
off and do the things that I want to do
and so the 254 confidence series that I
talked about at the beginning is really
about everyday getting the video for
free in the morning that helps you build
your confidence and it's thirty Seconds
to five minutes just meant to be a
trigger for you that here I'm hanging
out with Oprah and here I'm hanging out
with Elon and here I'm hanging out with
Richard Branson and Steve Jobs then
they're giving me just a quick little
hit and the more you're around that the
more it's going to feed in to your
environment the more it's gonna feed
into your mindset to say I'm confident
I'm around I'm like these people I
belong here and it's gonna give you that
self belief to go off and do the things
that you want to do so those are my
seven reasons why you're not happy and
how to fix them I would love to know
which ones resonated most with you that
I missing eight nine ten that you want
to add to the list let me know down the
thoughts below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video